now is it possible to build muscle and
lose fat at the same exact time
well let's talk about each point and how
they relate to each other
let's start with exercise exercise is
responsible for about 15
of fat loss and so your diet would
contribute to about 85 percent
so there is some benefits of exercise
for
fat loss the key with building and
maintaining muscle growth
is this right here intensity of exercise
as well as the volume of exercise
because if you're doing
keto and you're losing weight and you
drop out your exercise
you're not going to continue to build
muscle in fact it might
shrink a couple other points to consider
recovery of the exercise if you over
train
and don't recover let's say you're
working out every single day
and also adding on to that you're not
sleeping because you're stressed out
then the benefit of this is not going to
be there so you really need all these
factors in place
the cool thing about exercise is it can
stimulate growth hormone
up to 700 that's huge
and growth hormone helps you build
muscle
now let's switch to the carbs the lower
the carb
the more the weight loss right but carbs
stimulate insulin which is an
anabolic hormone it makes things
grow so now we have a problem if we go
with too many carbs over 50 grams
it's going to stop the weight loss
but what if we did this what if we
consumed
a little more protein what if we kept
our carbs lower
definitely below 50 grams and we
increased our protein
a little bit more than 8 ounces per meal
what that's going to do it's going to
increase insulin
and glucagon now i will say that too
much protein can potentially slow down
your weight loss
so it's a bit of a balancing act
between having the right amount of
protein and the right amount of carbs so
maybe you're going to play around
between 30 to 50 grams of
carbs and keep your protein between 8
ounces and then maybe try to increase it
a little bit
to actually provide a little bit more
insulin to the muscles
but at the same time increasing glucagon
which actually
helps you burn more fat and so this
point right here the carb amount and
protein amount is an individual thing
you have to play around with this
to get the sweet spot but i just want
you to understand the relationship
between these two
fat provides energy for doing more
exercise if you go low fat
and you're doing fasting you could
potentially make your body a bit too
tired and not have the energy to do the
exercise so we need a certain amount of
fat
we don't want to go below 75 grams
and that will force your body to burn
more of its own fat
and not turn the dietary fat
as much into ketones but having
sufficient amounts of dietary fat
in your diet will definitely help the
next factor right here which is
fasting fasting is the most powerful
thing
to lose weight because it dramatically
brings your insulin
way down and if you're doing consistent
fasting
you can handle a little more protein
because you're going to give your body a
chance and the time to digest
a larger amount of protein now as far as
fasting and your muscles go when you
fast you could potentially stimulate
growth hormone
up to 2 000 percent now let's compare
this
to exercise which is 700 percent you get
a major
spike in growth hormone when you do
fasting
and growth hormone is all about building
muscle and when you fast there's also a
protein
sparing effect that occurs and that
means simply that your body is not going
to be using your own muscle protein
as fuel it protects the muscles
of course there's going to be a point
where you burn off all your fat
and then the body is going to starve and
use its muscles but
it's not going to happen when you do
routine fasting or even periodic
prolonged fasting
one point about fasting it's very
important
to consume enough sea salt about one to
one and a half teaspoons a day
with potassium and magnesium to get your
electrolytes
if you don't do this your energy is
going to go down
it's called keto fatigue and you will
not be able to
exercise because your muscles are not
going to have
the electrolytes they're going to get
tired in
all of your cells you have what's called
a sodium potassium
pump that generates the electrical
energy to allow the muscles and nerve to
work
so as you can see now the importance of
how these different factors relate to
each other
to build muscle while you
lose the fat
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today